one of the things that i often do on
pftpm i take your questions we're taking
your questions right here and right now
chris sims you put the call out last
night i echoed it and i think we got
enough to work with let's start with all
things giants if if the vikings make it
all the way to the super bowl will mike
promise to dress like prince
mike will not dress how do you f where
do you go to find prince clothes i live
in west virginia okay i'm not gonna find
clothes that prince would have worn in
west virginia uh wait wait are you
kidding me with that crap are you
kidding me with that statement first of
all there's got to be a halloween store
by second of all there's this new
invention called the internet all right
so nice i've never heard of that yeah
yeah nice try with that bullcrap
statement there
i think it's kind of good i'm not
familiar with this thing that i've used
to fashion a career that didn't exist 20
years ago exactly you could go on there
and get like a shiny black perm hair and
a purple
vest with no undershirt and show your
chest hairs and your arm muscles and
some tight like purple leather pants i
like it i like where your head's at at
giant things
i like that
not happening all right all right marvin
martin that's the end of it marvin blue
what can the packers do to stay in first
place in the nfc north or north also
with thanksgiving coming up what are you
what's up we're doing the whole so are
we starting already what's your favorite
side dish stuff let's just focus on the
packers
what is it i want to know
how is it not stuffing you have stuffing
once a year yes it's got it it's always
stuffing it isn't that weird like we
love the food that we eat on
thanksgiving and christmas well why
don't we make it the rest of the year
it's not like it's ridiculously
expensive it's not like we caviar at the
holidays you could have turkey and
stuffing any time you want why do we
wait until then and once thanksgiving
comes i do have it i think you know more
than just thanksgiving and christmas
during the winter time uh but stuffing
is like i mean it's just absolutely
phenomenal i'm simple on thanksgiving
give me turkey give me mashed potatoes
give me stuffing and some gravy on top
and i'm going to go back for three or
four helpings that's all i need i don't
even give a crap about all the other
stuff
all right what do the packers have to do
to stay in first place in the in the nfc
north well i think we hit it a little
bit on the pod just we did a few minutes
ago when we kind of broke down their
offense it is stay patient with their
run game you know they have to stay
patient with the run game because that's
when they're at the best offensively
they don't have the weapons in the pass
game to just get in shootouts with team
teams that way where they can just get
in the shotgun and say oh aaron rodgers
you know throw it 45 times a game and
we'll throw for 480 yards no there's not
a talent not enough talent there but
their o-line is pretty good aaron jones
is showing that he's very good and the
other thing that's going to help when
they play that aspect it helps create
big plays like we saw last week but it's
going to help their defense which is you
know truly truly struggling you know
their defense can't stop the run they
have interior defense problems as far as
d tackles middle linebackers and that's
a big problem for the green bay packers
in general and that's where the offense
i think has to help out the defense and
the team by playing that way
and here's the thing even though they've
had a special season so far and they're
eight and two the vikings are right on
their heels they are and i feel like
it's gonna come down to the last two
games for the packers at minnesota at
detroit they're gonna need to win one of
those games maybe both to nail down the
division title and it could be that that
nfc north championship game happens a
week early week 16 the last monday night
out of the sun football we got we got
the packers 49ers now on that uh the nfl
changed that that's great i mean i you
know that that gives us the the best
slate of games for the day now where we
don't have any games competing against
each other i'm i'm excited that that got
moved
yeah it was going to be 49ers packers at
the same time cowboys and patriots were
being played the nfl decided to slide
49ers packers to the night spot and
seattle philadelphia begins at 1 p.m
eastern so there's a great game in every
window and seahawks fans have already
whined about the fact that their team is
playing a game that starts at 10 a.m
local time look they're on a buy this
week they can go to philadelphia a day
early and get acclimated if they need to
so don't complain too much it's not like
it's happening this week after playing
70 minutes of football on a monday night
all right pft pam posse has a question
are dak and amari not signing new
contracts with the cowboys because
they're waiting to see what happens with
the head coach and the coaching staff
chris well i mean i don't know what your
thoughts are there but i don't think
that has anything to do with it i think
amari cooper realizes he's a smart guy
like hey he went through a little lull
with the oakland raiders he did get
drafted in the top five he's making a
ton of money this year right he's making
what over 14 million this year mike so
he's not like desperate for cash dak
prescott i think is just holding out
he's waiting to get a contract where he
feels like it
it it takes advantage or shows his true
worth to the team but i don't think uh
the head coaching and coaching staff has
anything to do with it with these two
what do you think
i agree with you completely this is
about what value these guys have and
they're letting it play out remember
back early in the off season we said
there's wisdom in these two guys
agreeing they're not going to do
anything because next year there's only
one franchise tag available to be used
on dak prescott now a transition tag
would be available if they don't do any
cba because it's the last year of the
current deal and teams have one
franchise tag and one transition tag
available in the last year of the cba
but the transition tag is meaningless it
just gives you a right to match gives
you no compensation i think they have to
worry about amari cooper leaving on the
open market or via the transition tag
and with dak prescott this is all about
getting his value it's not about who the
next coach is going to be or if there is
going to be a new coach this is about
getting his value and we are careening
toward an off season that will be very
interesting because his value is going
to be set by the franchise tag and
they're going to use either the
non-exclusive tag at 26 million or so
for 2020 or the exclusive tag which
prevents any team from signing him to an
offer sheet that's going to be about 33
million for one year and here's the
other thing to watch chris keep an eye
on this when kirk cousins got tagged by
washington he was there for everything
in the off-season training camp
preseason he's good to go
le'veon bell did the other thing in 2017
he didn't show up until it was time for
the season to start i think if dak
prescott gets franchise tag the cowboys
need to worry about him not showing up
and if they do make a coaching change
good luck getting your new offense right
in place if you're starting quarterback
is not showing up because he's been
franchise tagged and he's refused to
sign it so keep an eye on that but i
think it's all about the value of the
players it has nothing to do with
waiting to see who the coach is going to
be all right k tom 24 of the teams
currently on the bubble who is more
likely most likely to sneak into the
playoffs well i go with the philadelphia
eagles right off the bat i mean that's
just the team that jumps out to me the
other one you know i'll throw out there
is is the oakland raiders you know i
just look at them they don't have a
daunting schedule down the stretch they
can run the ball control the clock that
way i think john gruden's doing a really
really good job uh those are i think are
the two teams that jump out to me more
than the rest
yeah i agree with you i mean the
steelers i believe in and even though
they're
with their backup quarterback mason
rudolph he was praised by the coaching
staff for his performance against the
rams and he's moving in the right
direction
and there's just something about that
steelers team they have stumbled into
this vibe this kind of special feeling i
saw with them in 1989 when they were
blown out the first two games of the
year and left for dead they made it the
final eight that year i think this team
can continue to achieve and the eagles i
mean
they're they're not on the bubble
they're on the inside i mean yes they
technically are behind the cowboys
because the cowboys won the game two
teams played a few weeks ago in texas
but they're both five and four and the
eagles i think have a favorable schedule
in comparison to cowboys down the
stretch i don't think the cowboys are
going to make the playoffs it's scary
that's sunday night game as we kind of
digest what happened to the cowboys on
sunday night
i think they're not going to make the
playoffs and i think jason carroll is
going to be out of a job it doesn't look
good right now and the colts
the colts with jacobi percept we got to
mention them too they're still going to
be a force in the afc in that
conversation i think i i think the
jaguars are the team to watch not
because you and i both picked them to
win the division but they're getting
nick falls back they're four and five it
feels like they're worse than four and
five they are right there in striking
distance to make a run at the top of the
uh the division the problem is they've
been swept by the texans and they're two
games behind the texans yeah no yeah
you're right that's going to be the afc
south with all them playing each other
and everything there there's still a lot
of work to be done and you're right that
could shuffle out a lot of different
ways
all right here's one for chris from at
the cj newman chris do you feel that
sometimes you weren't considered for
employment solely based on the fact that
you're left-handed to offense to switch
personnel of the line to adjust to the
blind side for lefties well no i think
the times i wasn't considered for
employment was just at the point of my
career where people didn't think i was
good enough and it had nothing to do
with me being lefty or writing now when
i got to teams and did have to play you
know whether it was john gruden or when
i went to the tennessee titans or josh
mcdaniels the denver broncos you know i
think there was some times where they're
like oh wait i can't call that play this
way for you your lefty let me re-juggle
it in my head and do they look at me
like oh you pain in the ass left eu yes
but uh at the end of the day i don't
think it was a a difference maker that
way
and look i like to bust your chops from
time to time but i give you credit for
going through everything you went
through with the spleen
and the issues and the adjustment and
just how long it took to fully recover
from that and the fight there and to
keep it it would have been easy to say
screw it i've made my money i'm getting
out of here but you kept with it for
several more years even though it had to
be frustrating to have to completely
relearn how to throw a football and
relearn how to play quarterback yeah it
was it was it was uh it was a daily
struggle i woke up stressed every day
for about two years like is this the day
i'm gonna feel normal is this the day i
can throw a spiral again is this the day
i can put some rpms on the ball and some
mile per hours on the ball uh so it was
very annoying but you know hey it all
worked out i've been very blessed in my
life in a lot of different ways and i
knew the price of uh you know battle on
the football field i knew that ray lewis
and julius peppers crushing me wasn't
good for my health and that's just the
price of doing business but i love the
game and i wasn't gonna just quit just
because of the injury
would you do it again knowing what you
know now definitely i would no doubt
about it nothing that can replace it man
running out in the field on a sunday
running out in the field to start a
playoff game there's nothing that can
compare to the adrenaline the feeling
the fear the emotions the camaraderie
with your team it is very special
feelings uh and those are the things you
know i i miss most about it or missed
the most about it especially my first
few years out of the league
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports